Marisa es un amante de los gatos
actualmente cuida de varios pero no puede resistirse a adoptar otro pequeño y adorable amigo peludo.
Después de mudarse a una casa más grande,
Marisa comienza a adoptar gatos a un ritmo constante.
El número de gatos en la nueva casa de Marisa, "G",
como función del tiempo
desde que se mudó (en días), "t",
se ilustra en la gráfica a continuación,
en esta gráfica de acá abajo.
Basándote en la gráfica.
¿Cuál de las siguientes proposiciones es correcta?
Y aquí me dan varias opciones,
vamos a checar cada una
y vamos a ver que podemos deducir.
Marisa tenía 10 gatos cuando se mudó de casa
y adopta dos nuevos gatos cada día.
Bueno veamos,
Marisa se mudó de casa en el día 0
el día 0, es su primer día en la nueva casa,
por lo tanto los gatos que tuviera en el día 0,
serían los gatos
con los que llegó a su casa nueva.
Por lo tanto, aquí veo que en "t" igual a 0,
si se corresponde a 10 gatos.
Puedo decir que el punto 0,10 está en la gráfica,
por lo tanto, cuando se acababa de mudar,
sí tenía 10 gatos.
Entonces, esta parte es correcta,
y adopta dos nuevos gatos cada día.
Bueno, para ver eso lo que vamos a hacer, es tratar de calcular, a qué ritmo está  Marisa adoptando gatos.
Vamos a ver,
necesito encontrar otro punto sobre la gráfica
que sea fácil de leer,
que tenga coordenadas sencillas,
este no... este no... este no... este no...
este no... este no...,
¡este punto es bueno!
Este punto de aquí parece que tiene coordenadas,
15,40
este es el punto, 15,40
Con estos dos puntos voy a tratar de calcular,
a qué ritmo está adoptando gatos Marisa,
que de hecho, eso equivale
a encontrar la pendiente de esta línea recta
pero bueno, veamos,
si pasamos de 0...
perdón de 0 días,
hasta 15 días,
entonces tengo un cambio,
un cambio en el tiempo de
15 días...
15 días.
y ¿qué pasó con el número de gatos?
pues cambio de estar en 10 a llegar hasta 40,
Marisa está adoptando gatos
a una velocidad bastante...
bastante rápida,
y de hecho en algún momento
tendría que parar en la vida real,
pero como es un problema de matemáticas
podemos idealizarlo.
Así que paso de aquí, de estar a 10,
a estar a 40,
por lo tanto el cambio,
el cambio en la cantidad de gatos,
delta "G"
es igual a 40 menos 10 que es 30.
De donde, la velocidad
con la que Marisa está adoptando gatos,
sería igual a
el cambio del número de gatos
dividido entre el cambio en el
tiempo correspondiente
al cambio del número de gatos.
El cambio número de gatos decía que era 30
y el cambio en el tiempo era 15,
por lo tanto Marisa adopta 30 gatos cada 15 días
o lo que es lo mismo,
2 gatos cada día...
2 gatos,
por cada unidad de tiempo que son días.
Por lo tanto,
es cierto que adopta dos nuevos gatos cada día.
Y bueno esto es opción múltiple,
así que probablemente esta sea la respuesta correcta,
pero vamos a checar las demás.
Marisa tenía tres gatos cuando se mudó de casa y adopta dos nuevos gatos cada día,
pues sabemos que no tenía tres gatos,
tres gatos sería
si la gráfica pasará por aquí más o menos,
pero, sabemos que tenía 10 gatos cuando llegó,
así que esto no es cierto.
Marisa tenía 10 gatos cuando se mudó,
esa parte cierta,
y adopta un nuevo gato cada dos días, pues no,
acabamos de calcular que adopta dos gatos cada día, por lo tanto esto tampoco tiene sentido.
Marisa tenía tres gatos cuando se mudó de casa
y adopta un nuevo gato cada dos días,
de nuevo, tres gatos está mal,
noten,
finalmente que...
la pendiente de esto sí tiene sentido,
si Marisa adopta dos gatos cada día
entonces después de 15 días,
el número de gatos debía haber aumentado en 30,
que es precisamente lo que sucede aquí.
Así que bueno,
la primer respuesta es la correcta.